i just finished the six mile run in uh
good old below freezing boston weather a
bit too dark a bit too icy but
probably good for the mind and soul so i
thought it'd be a good time to make this
video and say that
for the second year now mr david goggins
is doing the 4x4 by 48 challenge
at 8 pm pacific on friday march 5th
that's running 48 miles in 48 hours by
doing four miles every four hours
but this time friends him and i are
doing it together
in person just him and i probably in the
middle of a desert somewhere
probably with just one of us returning
home alive
and i think you know which one it is
we'll do a podcast before
and after also he'll go live on
instagram at the beginning of every four
hour leg
i have not been training much at all to
be honest
and this video is a quick explanation of
how i'm training for this challenge
starting today in a way that gives me a
reasonable fitness base
while still letting me be productive in
all the different things i have going on
i took on this challenge with david uh
on a bit of a leap
of faith and a bit of madness in order
to test myself mentally and physically
but also because i often take this kind
of leap into things
that seem very stupid at the time but
when all is said and done
i almost always become a better person
because of it so if you're out there a
little bit out of shape
like me i'm hoping you join me in
getting back to exercising this month
and
perhaps taking on the challenge along
with me along with david along with us
if you're not a runner you can just do
some sort of exercise for 40 to 60
minutes every four hours instead
if you want to get involved check links
in the description for more information
i think but mostly just tag me and david
if you're stepping your fitness up in
any kind of way this month as you train
and if you're participating in the
challenge i know it'll be inspiring to
me to see
anybody who's just getting out there
since to be honest
this would be a ridiculously big
challenge for me
with everything i have going on so i can
probably use all the uh
inspiration you got okay so training
wise check out the google sheet of my
training in the description
but it's pretty basic the focus as usual
is to establish a ritual a habit of
daily exercise
and then increasing duration a little
bit every week so maybe let me first
speak to the principle of that
i know that for muscle building and for
increasing race performance
it's good to mix up workouts from
long to short sprints that kind of thing
with rest days and
just mixing it up throughout the week
but i don't know about anyone else but
for me
that has only really worked when i'm
already in really good shape
what for me has been more beneficial
more effective
is to focus on building up the habit of
exercise every day the same thing
the habit and ritual of it lessens the
need
and the reliance on motivation on
day-to-day motivation
so for me the training is easily
integrated into the day has two parts
one is cardio
one is body weight exercises and the
schedule is
pretty basic i run a medium distance
every day monday through friday
and the long distance run on saturday
and then rest on sunday
so specifically for me that means week
one what i'm doing now
six miles each day then week two is
seven miles week three is eight miles
week four is nine miles so we're about
four and a half weeks off from the
challenge
i think two or three days before the
challenge i'll take complete rest days
so my recommendation to you for what
it's worth is
to pick a cardio exercise that you can
stick to on a daily basis
so running cycling swimming even walking
and just build the habit and do an
intensity and duration
that doesn't break your body down but
it's still challenging just keeps
challenging you but not too much
not causing injury not causing over
exertion over exhaustion
on the bodyweight exercise side for me
that's six days of exercise that
includes push-ups pull-ups
bodyweight squats and these ab roller
things
for the abs for the core i do it in
rounds of
20 push-ups 10 pull-ups
10 ab rollers and 10 squats my
recommendation
again take it with a grain of salt is if
you do body weight exercises
pick numbers within the round that
allows you to do
timed rounds without much rest in
between
maybe no more than one minute's rest and
do essentially
a full body workout but not to
exhaustion and i know
a lot of people are going to say you
know rest days are really essential you
want to alternate upper body lower body
push-pull
all those kinds of things all of that is
true when you're trying to achieve
maximum performance
what i find for me in a busy life when i
have a million things going on
building the habit building the ritual
of exercise
and not pushing myself to exhaustion is
the most effective way to stay healthy
and just to feel good
and make sure the exercise stays part of
my life
you probably didn't ask me but that's my
recommendation if you're starting from
being kind of out of shape to building
up shape for doing something like that
48 mile challenge
but you should also definitely read a
lot of different advice that's out there
and
integrate it in a way that works for
your own schedule for your own body all
that kind of stuff
on the diet side i'm eating clean as
usual just meat and veggies
the veggies are mostly cauliflower and
green beans my two favorites
and on the meat side is ground beef
actually from
bel campo farms they sent me a ton of
meat and is delicious
on the supplement side i'm doing the
usual
athletic greens every morning plus fish
oil
and electrolytes before and after the
run
you should definitely check out athletic
greens and belcampo
farms they uh are both somehow amazingly
now sponsors of the podcast that i host
after i posted about how much i love
their stuff
and also check out cauliflower
especially in rice form
it's a game changer so at least my
training
regimen is pretty simple run basically
every day bodyweight exercises every day
don't
over exert and gradually increase the
duration of the exercise
and the rest is just in the mind and i'm
hoping i am uh mentally tough enough to
not die with tayyakins
i thought to post this video you know
hopefully to inspire others to
step up their exercise game this month
to run to cycle all that kind of stuff
and maybe even join in on this crazy
challenge
i think it's a really perfect balance of
testing the body and mind
just being able to persevere through
this 48 hour period
it's just long enough to where it's not
this kind of
shorter marathon run of suffering you
kind of have to suffer just a little bit
every four hours it's honestly just a
huge honor to be able to do this kind of
thing with
uh david goggins we were just supposed
to do the podcast but of course
as he does with everybody he meets he
pulls you in
and challenges you to uh push yourself
to your own limits to discover yourself
and
i think that's kind of what this whole
life is about is to do difficult things
and in the process be able to discover
something about yourself
that you wouldn't be able to discover in
any kind of way there's some kind of
magic in the challenge
that allows you to put a mirror to
yourself to meet your demons
to overcome them and then the rest of
life becomes easy or at least easier
the training in boston is uh definitely
a bit rough right now
it's been below freezing for many days
in a row so it's uh
it's starting to feel a lot like rocky
iv
except in this version the russian is
the out-of-shape
underdog training in the snow and it's
the
american who says uh if he dies he dies
so we'll see what happens i love you all
you